[Music]
last video I left you with a puzzle the
setup involves two sliding blocks in a
perfectly idealized world where there's
no friction and all collisions are
perfectly elastic meaning no energy is
lost one block is sent towards another
smaller one which starts off stationary
and there's a wall behind it so that the
smaller block bounces back and forth
until it redirects the big blocks
momentum enough to fully turn around
sailing away from the wall if that first
block has a mass which is a power of 100
times the mass of the second for example
a million times as much an insanely
surprising fact popped out the total
number of collisions including those
between the second mass and the wall has
the same starting digits as pi in this
example that's 3141 collisions if that
first block was a trillion times the
mass it would be three million 141,000
592 collisions before this happens
almost all of which happen in one huge
unrealistic burst and speaking of
unexpectedly big bursts in the short
time since that video went out lots of
people have been sharing solutions and
attempts and simulations which is
awesome so why does this happen
why should PI show up in such an
unexpected place and in such an
unexpected manner for most this is a
lesson about using phase space also
commonly called configuration space to
solve problems so rest assured that
you're not just learning about some
esoteric algorithm for pi this tactic
here is core to many other fields and
it's a useful tool to keep in your belt
to start when one block hits another how
do you figure out the velocity of each
one after the collision the key is to
use the conservation of energy together
with the conservation of momentum let's
go ahead and call their masses m1 and m2
and their velocities V 1 and V 2 which
will be the variables changing
throughout the process at any given
point the total kinetic energy is
one-half m1 times v1 squared plus
one-half m2 times v2 squared so even
though v1 and v2 will be changing as the
blocks get bumped around the
value of this expression must remain
constant the total momentum of the two
blocks is m1 times v1 plus m2 times v2
this also has to remain constant when
the blocks hit each other but it can
change as the second block bounces off
the wall in reality the second block
would transfer its momentum to the wall
during this collision and again we're
being idealistic say thinking of that
wall as having infinite mass so such a
momentum transfer won't actually move
the wall so here we have 2 equations and
2 unknowns to put these to use try
drawing a picture to represent the
equations you might start by focusing on
the energy equation since V 1 and V 2
are changing maybe you think to
represent the equation on a coordinate
plane where X is equal to V 1 and Y is
equal to V 2 so individual points on
this plane encode the pair of velocities
of our block in that case the energy
equation represents an ellipse where
each point of this ellipse gives you a
pair of velocities all of which
correspond to the same total kinetic
energy in fact let's actually change our
coordinates a little bit to make this
into a perfect circle since we know that
we're on a hunt for pie instead of
having the x coordinate represent V 1
let it be the square root of M 1 times V
1 which for this example shown stretches
the figure in the X direction by the
square root of 10 likewise have the y
coordinate represent square root of m2
times V 2 that way when you look at the
conservation of energy equation what
it's saying is 1/2 x squared plus y
squared equals some constant which is
the equation for a circle which specific
circle depends on the total energy but
that actually doesn't matter for our
problem at the beginning when the first
block is sliding to the left and the
second one is stationary were at the
leftmost point on the circle right where
the x coordinate is negative and the y
coordinate is 0 what about right after
the collision how do we know what
happens conservation of energy tells us
that we must jump to some other point of
the circle but which one well use the
conservation of momentum this tells us
that before and after the collision the
value of m1 times v1 plus m2 times v2
must stay constant in our rescaled
coordinates
that looks like saying square root of M
1 times X plus square root of M 2 times
y equals some constant and that's the
equation for a line specifically aligned
with a slope of negative square root of
M 1 over M 2 you might ask which
specific line and that depends on what
the constant momentum is but we know
that it must pass through our first
point and that locks us into one choice
so just to be clear about what all this
is saying all other pairs of velocities
which would give the same momentum live
on this line in just the same way that
all of the pairs of velocities that give
the same energy live on this circle so
notice this gives us one and only one
other point that we could jump to and it
should make sense that it's something
where the x-coordinate gets a little
less negative and the y coordinate
becomes negative since that corresponds
to the big block slowing down a little
while the little block zooms off towards
the wall from here it's quite fun to see
how things play out when the second
block bounces off the wall its speed
stays the same but it goes from negative
to positive right so in this diagram
that corresponds to reflecting about the
x axis
since the y-coordinate gets multiplied
by negative 1 then once more the next
collision corresponds to a jump along a
line with slope negative square root of
M 1 over M 2 since staying on such a
line is what conservation of momentum
looks like in this diagram and from here
you can fill in the rest for how the
block collisions correspond to hopping
around the circle in our picture where
we keep going like this until the
velocity of that smaller block is both
positive and smaller than the velocity
of the big one meaning they'll never
touch again that corresponds to this
triangular region in the upper right of
the diagram so in our process we keep
bouncing until we land in that region
what we've drawn here is called a phase
diagram which is a simple but powerful
idea in math where you encode the state
of some system in this case the
velocities of our sliding blocks as a
single point in some abstract space
what's powerful here is that it turns
questions about dynamics into questions
about geometry in this case the
dynamical idea of all possible pairs of
velocities that conserve energy
corresponds to the geometric idea of a
circle and counting the total number of
collisions turns into counting the total
number of hops along these lines
alternating between vertical and
diagonal but our question remains why is
it that when that mass ratio is a power
of 100 the total number of steps shows
the digits of pi well if you stare at
this picture maybe just maybe you'd
notice that all of the arc lengths
between the points on this circle seem
to be about the same it's not
immediately obvious that this should be
true but if it is it means that
computing the value of one such arc
length should be enough to figure out
how many total collisions it takes to
get us into that end zone the key here
is to use the ever helpful inscribed
angle theorem which says that whenever
you're forming an angle using three
points on a circle p1 p2 and p3 like
this it will be exactly half of the
angle formed by p1 the circle Center and
p3 p2 can be anywhere on the circle
anywhere except between p1 and p3 and
this lovely little fact will be true so
now look back at our phase space and
focus specifically on three points like
these remember that first vertical hop
corresponds to the second block bouncing
off the wall and that second hop along a
slope of negative square root of M 1
over M 2 corresponds to a momentum
conserving block collision let's call
the angle between this momentum line and
the vertical line theta and now maybe
you see it using the inscribed angle
theorem this arc length between those
two bottom points measured in radians
will be 2 theta
and importantly since the momentum line
has the same slope for all of those
jumps from the top of the circle to the
bottom the same reasoning means that all
of these arc lengths must also be 2
theta so for each hop if we drop down a
new arc like so then after each
collision we cover another 2 theta
radians of the circle we stop once we're
in that end zone on the right which
remember corresponds to both blocks
moving to the right with the smaller one
going slower but you can also think of
this as stopping at the point when
adding one more arc of 2 theta would
overlap with the previous one in other
words how many times do you have to add
2 theta to itself before it covers more
than the whole circle more than 2 pi
radians the answer to this will be the
same as the number of collisions between
our blocks or to say the same thing more
compactly what's the largest integer
multiple of theta that doesn't surpass
pi for example if theta was 0.01 radians
then multiplying it by as much as 314
would keep you below pie but multiplying
by 315 would bring you over that value
so the answer would be 314 meaning if
our mass ratio was one such that the
angle theta in our diagram was 0.01 then
the blocks would collide 314 times
so now you know what we need to do let's
go ahead and actually compute the value
theta say when the mass ratio is 100 to
1 remember this rise over run slope of
that constant momentum line was the
negative square root of M 1 over M 2
which in this example is negative 10
that would mean that the tangent of this
angle theta opposite over adjacent is
the run over the negative rise so to
speak which is 1/10 in this example so
theta is going to be the arc tan of 1/10
speaking more generally it'll be the
inverse tangent of the square root of
the small mass over the square root of
the big mass if you go ahead and plug
these into a calculator what you'd
notice is that the inverse tangent of
such a small value is actually quite
close to the value itself for example
arc tan of 1 over 100 corresponding to a
big mass of 10,000 kilograms is
extremely close to 0.01 in fact it's so
close that for the sake of our central
question it might as well be 0.01 and
what I mean by that is analogous to what
we saw a moment ago adding this to
itself as many as 314 times won't
surpass PI but the 315th time would and
remember unraveling why we're doing all
this that's a way of counting how many
jumps on the phase diagram gets us into
the endzone which in turn is a way of
counting how many times the blocks
collide until they're sailing off never
to catch again so that my friends is why
a mass ratio of 10,000 gives 314
collisions like why is a mass ratio of a
million-to-one will give an angle theta
equals the inverse tangent of one over a
thousand this is extremely close to
0.001 and again if we ask about the
largest integer multiple of this angle
that doesn't surpass pi it's the same as
it would be for a precise value of 0.001
namely 3141 these are the first four
digits of pi because that is by
definition what digits of a number me
this explains why when the mass ratio is
a million the number of collisions is
3141 you might notice that all of this
relies on the hope that the inverse
tangent of a small value is sufficiently
close to the value itself which is
another way of saying that the tangent
of a small value is approximately that
value itself intuitively there's a
really nice reason this is true if you
look at a unit circle the tangent of any
given angle is the height of this little
triangle I've drawn divided by its width
and when that angle is really small the
width is basically 1 the radius of your
circle and the height is basically the
same as the arc length along that circle
and by definition that arc length is
Theta to be more precise about it the
Taylor series expansion of tangent of
theta shows that this approximation will
have only a cubic error term so for
example the tangent of 1/100 differs
from 1/100 itself by something on the
order of 1 1 millionth so even if we
were to consider 314 steps with this
angle the error between the actual value
of arctan 1 over 100 and the
approximation of 0.01 it just won't have
a chance to accumulate high enough to be
as big as an integer so let's zoom out
and sum up when blocks collide you can
figure out their new velocities by
slicing a line through a circle in a
velocity phase diagram where each of
these curves represents a conservation
law most notably the conservation of
energy is what plants that circular seed
that ultimately blossoms into the pie
that we find in the final count
specifically due to some inscribed angle
geometry the points that we hit of this
circle are spaced out evenly separated
by an angle that we were calling to
theta this lets us rephrase the question
of counting collisions as instead asking
how many times must we add 2 theta to
itself before it surpasses 2 pi if theta
looks something like 0.001
the answer to that question has the same
first digits as pi and when the mass
ratio is some power of 100 because
arctan of x is so well approximated by x
for small values theta is sufficiently
close to this value that it gives the
same final count I'll emphasize again
what this phase space allowed us to do
because as I said this is a lesson
useful for all sorts of math like
differential equations and chaos theory
and other flavors of dynamics by
representing the relevant state of your
system as a single point in an abstract
space it lets you translate problems of
dynamics into problems of geometry I
repeat myself because I don't want you
to come away just remembering a neat
puzzle where PI shows up unexpectedly I
want you to remember the surprise
appearance as it is still remnant of the
deeper relationship at play and if this
solution leaves you feeling satisfied it
shouldn't because there is another
perspective more clever and pretty than
this one due to galperin in his original
paper on this phenomenon which invites
us to draw a striking parallel between
the dynamics of these blocks and that of
a beam of light bouncing between two
mirrors trust me
I've saved the best for last on this
topic so I hope to see you again in the
next video
[Music]